ces gestes josé les connaît par coeur
désormais depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire duo kobe 19
ce chauffeur de taxi doit faire
attention à l'hygiène de vie de son
véhicule
quitte à mettre la main à la pâte j'ai
fait attention je vous en fait les mois
sans arrêt merci qu'on a pas que ça
s'arrête pas qu'aux autres chauffeurs
depuis 42 ans
josé vie comme tous ses collègues une
situation inédite s'il continue à sortir
pour travailler des précautions sont
prises
et il ne sort pas sans son nouvel
équipement désinfectant lingettes gants
et le fameux masque de nouvelles
habitudes à prendre avec les clients
également ont fait un jeu mais derrière
comme ça ce côté là bas et bomba ont
tous eu droit qu à l vos clips qu'ils
rookies ont pas le la maladie alex lui
aussi prend ses précautions
l'équipement est là même si pour lui
tout n'est pas forcément une obligation
j'ai une boîte de grands ou des grands
serveurs bien comprendre ce qu'on dit
sur les gants vaut mieux avoir échelle
et manu vous avez une utilisation
les gants par contre dès que vous
touchez quelque chose pour les jeter
moi je dis que c'est de l'argent coûte
un rein malgré toutes ces précautions
des risques existent toujours une
désinfection est bel et bien fait mais
pas après chaque client car trop
contraignante est une perte de temps
de nouvelles habitudes à prendre mais
qui semble logique non sens faut
reconnaître qu'il ya un sens ça donne
dans tout ça sinon elle ne demanderait
pas de le faire je pense si ça n'avait
pas de sens il demanderait pas de le
faire faut être logique
les chauffeurs vont devoir poursuivre
leur nouvelle routine qu'il pourquoi pas
pourrait poursuivre même après la fin de
la crise sanitaire